the jurogan experience so i
when i started i moved to uh actually i
have a story with you
oh yeah about first starting oh you were
responsible for basically the first time
i ever went on stage
uh i mean almost in a comment i think
zany chicago might have been the first
actual club i went to is he that or the
comedy store
so i was friends with uh a buddy of mine
josh baker he was in the band prom
kings do you remember band i think sure
yeah yeah
and so we came out to la to stay
hanging out with him and he uh and so
they knew you
and so this is i mean i think it's 2003
or four
and i've been to a comedy maybe a year
and so we come out
and then we you invite us to the show at
the comedy store so we come watch you we
sit in the front row i remember
all this stuff that's like a nightmare
as a comment now when you think back
then i didn't care
had you been thinking about doing it
already i already started i moved to
chicago so i was in
i was in chicago with like hannibal and
pete holmes and tj miller and kumail
like that was kind of the group that was
in chicago so i'm we went from chicago
to la to go just visit
and so we hung out with them we go to
your show you introduced them
at one of their shows because i guess
you were good friends with these people
or
with the with the band or you liked this
band and so you introduced them and i
remember i talked to you
afterwards like we were like at the show
and i'm like talking about comedy i'm
trying not to be i'm
a new comic so i don't even really know
what to ask
you were very very nice and then uh we
go watch you and then you said you're
going to go up at the comedy store i was
like it was when you had to sign up for
the open mic
the week later so you signed up for the
monday to go up the next week
and i was like well i was like i'm not
going to be here and uh
you go i'll call and then you got me on
stage that you called and said hey he's
just in town doing this how many dude
i'm a year coming
look at it so it worked out it worked
out dude
they brought me up they go uh this next
uh one of joe rogan's best friends
and they were i mean other comics are
just furious and i'm like i don't
i was like we met him last night he's a
very nice guy
that's a funny thing man the those
little like
nudges and like uh little pieces of
good like uh like criticism
or good you know a praise from
a comic when you're starting out like
that could go so far
so far from i remember to this day like
uh
lenny clark i'd done stand-up i'd done
it for like
a year and i'd gotten paid one time
before this is the second time i ever
got paid
and i opened up for lenny clark in
pittsfield massachusetts this was after
i
think i've done this show this gig yeah
is that jay's
jays and pittsburgh was it in a hotel um
i don't think so
i've done a pittsfield mascot oh it was
uh like a nightclub
and it was it was like one of the best
road gigs like everybody get
it it was a three-hour drive from boston
but it was one of those road gigs where
everybody
would get excited and this was after
lenny had been on hbo
he was on the ronnie dangerfield young
comedian special
ronnie whatever ronnie called it and so
see just being around him was crazy
and then opening for him was even more
crazy and then after i got off stage he
was like kid you're really funny
like with that crazy boston accent and
man that powered me
through like years for three years i was
i was like oh man i'm doing this like
i'm i'm never quitting now
like lenny clark said i'm funny [ __ ]
yeah i'm good it's the
it's the it's gigantic yeah like that
was you doing that
at that time hey i knew the comedy story
but it's not like i
even really and then it was like going
to new york and then be like i've
already done the comedy store
and even as the open mic it was just i
saw the world and i got to see the world
and then talking to you at that
uh the band you were just talking about
going up and like you got to go up like
you know
stuff that you would say to comics but
it was like stuff that i didn't know at
that time
and you realize you know that that
that's enormous yeah that's enormous i
did that pittsfield mass gig
uh because i was in new york i opened up
for tony v
oh i love sony vs yeah and they i was
the host
got paid 500 bucks it was crazy like i
was like this is
crazy i've never paid 500 bucks for a
gift right it's packed
it's sold out i mean you just murder and
i thought maybe it wasn't at hotel i
don't remember
my wife with me it was a big night they
gave me 500 bucks cash i end up later on
tonight i lose the 500
oh no it just falls out why so the night
goes from this amazing night with my
wife for 500 bucks to now we're in a
fight
and uh i and but i mean i still think i
tell her every day
because at the time i was like were you
ever going to remember this 500 like i
always kind of live by that motto like
i'll get another 500 i bring it up still
i mean it's been
15 years and i still just go you
remember that 500 like just to make that
point
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience